5月21日 SpaceX向SEC提交了招股书
此次IPO预计募资750亿美元
上市当天市值有望超过2万亿美元
这样一次前后古人
后也很难有来者的人类史上最大IPO
我们来看看它的招股书中有哪些主流解读之外的亮点
首先 最意外 也是最重磅的消息
SpaceX与Anthropic签了大合同
Anthropic将向SpaceX每个月支付12.5亿美元购买算力
算力范围包括Colossus 1和Colossus 2两个数据中心集群
合同将执行到2029年5月
简单计算一下
这将为SpaceX带来每年150亿美元的巨额收入
根据财报披露的数字
SpaceX 2025年的年收入是187亿美元
与Anthropic签订的大合同
将把SpaceX的年收入提高超过百分之八十
这样的收入规模也将超过星链
成为SpaceX的最大单一收入来源
在这笔合同签订之前
SpaceX是一家由星链养着其他业务的公司
星舰的研发、AI的投入、X的经营
都在吞噬着现金流
有了这份3年总价值450亿美元的合同
星链也可以稍微松口气了
Anthropic面临的算力短缺
相信每一个Claude Code的用户都感同身受
虽然价格“小贵”
但提前锁定未来3年的大额算力 依旧合算
合同中还包含一个让人兴奋的隐藏条款
Anthropic表示有兴趣与SpaceX合作
开发吉瓦级的太空AI算力
也就是马斯克对资本市场讲的那个故事
太空数据中心
一天之后 马斯克发推说
我们有其他多家公司正在洽谈算力合同
强调一下
是多家 而不是一家
早已受限于算力不足
又是SpaceX大股东的Google
大概率会是下一个大客户
SpaceX在未来很可能会贴上一个新标签
一家超大号的Neo Cloud
招股书还披露
SpaceX现在持有18712枚比特币
SpaceX购入的比特币平均成本3.5万美元
按照今天的市值 约14.5亿美元
这让SpaceX的持币数量超过了特斯拉的11509枚
也超过了Coinbase的9267枚
在全世界能统计到的所有公司中排第11
在上市公司中排第5
排在SpaceX之前的公司
是MicroStrategy, Marathon Digital这样的屯币公司
或者Tether, Block.one这样的币圈公司
SpaceX是目前已知
非币圈公司里持有最多比特币的公司
在招股书中的董事会名单中
SpaceX的早期投资者悉数在列
我们来看看这8人的完整名单
这其中
Gwynne Shotwell是公司总裁
Donald Harrison代表谷歌
我们来看其他几个稍显陌生的名字
以及他们与SpaceX之间的往事
Ira Ehrenpreis是DBL Partners创始人
硅谷知名的投资人
也是“影响力投资“最早的倡导者之一
他是马斯克长达20年的坚定盟友和支持者
早在2006年
Ira还在上一家机构任职时
他就投资了特斯拉
并在2007年加入特斯拉董事会
今年2月
Ira加入SpaceX董事会 任独立董事
Ira的投资与马斯克高度绑定
他的基金还投资了Boring Company和Neuralink
Antonio Gracias执掌的Valor Equity Partners
也是在极早期支持了当时濒临倒闭的SpaceX
只比Founders Fund稍晚一些
Antonio与马斯克的渊源更深
早在2000年
Antonio就代表Valor的前身MG Capital
投资了刚刚完成合并的Paypal
并在05年投资了特斯拉
06年 Antonio加入特斯拉董事会
2008年 Valor投资了绝境中的SpaceX
随后 Antonio加入SpaceX董事会
此外 Antonio投资的马斯克系公司
还包括SolarCity、Neuralink以及合并之前的xAI
招股书显示
Valor Equity Partners及其关联实体的持股比例约7.3%
持股数量超过5亿股
如果按照上市当天1.75万亿的市值
Valor手中的股份价值将超过1000亿美元
与Antonio一样经历过公司至暗时刻的
还有Luke Nosek
Luke是Confinity的联合创始人
也是Confinity和X合并后组成的Paypal的早期高管
之后与大名鼎鼎的Peter Thiel
一起成立了Founders Fund
在第三次发射失败后的2008年8月
Luke和Peter Thiel
共同主导了SpaceX B轮2000万美元的融资
Founders Fund是当时唯一的外部机构投资者
随后 Luke代表Founders Fund加入董事会
SpaceX上市后
这笔投资可能会成为人类VC史上影响力最大
回报倍数最高的投资
2017年 Luke离开Founders Fund
成立Gigafund
这是一个专门投SpaceX的基金
也就是国内说的专项基金
Gigafund的LP几乎全是相信马斯克使命的长期投资者
Luke对外的说法是
这不是一个财务投资
而是一个使命投资
Steve Jurvetson和Randy Glein代表的是DFJ
这里重点说下Steve
你知道车架号0001
全世界第一辆量产版特斯拉Model S的车主是谁吗
以及 你知道全世界最后一辆Model S的车主是谁吗
都是Steve
Steve是整个硅谷与马斯克交情最为深厚的投资人
两人相识于30年前
他们第一次相识是1996年
马斯克去找Steve
希望他投资的自己的第一家公司Zip2
但当时Steve没有投资
后来Steve说这是他投资生涯最后悔的决定
于是他后来投资了马斯克的每一家公司
2008年下半年
特斯拉因为第一代跑车Roadster难产
而陷入严重的财务危机
濒临破产
Steve不仅代表DFJ投资了特斯拉
还利用个人影响力帮特斯拉到处找钱
2009年 DFJ领投了SpaceX约6000万美元的融资
2010年再次加注
并持续跟投后续轮次
Steve在DFJ和后来自己成立的Future Ventures
同样与马斯克深度绑定
是Boring Company和Neuralink的第一个外部投资者
看完了董事会名单
你可能会想
这董事会不就是马斯克和他的迷弟们组成的吗
事实也的确如此
与传统董事会强调独立董事的独立性
避免派系和关联性不同
SpaceX的董事会
很大程度上可能带来了
美国史上最激进的上市公司治理结构
马斯克一人控制约85%的投票权
在事实上决定了马斯克不可能被解雇
公司章程明确说了
所有股东索赔必须通过强制约束性仲裁解决
投资者被禁止在联邦法院提起任何诉讼
包括集体诉讼
《财富》杂志指出
此前没有任何美国主要上市公司采用过类似条款
只有持股超过3%的股东才能提起派生诉讼
即美国特有的
小股东代表公司起诉董事的诉讼
按1.75万亿美元估值计算
这意味着持股至少450亿美元才有资格起诉
对此 纽约州公共退休基金、加州公务员退休基金
和纽约市退休系统三家机构联合致函SpaceX
对上述治理条款表达严重关切
马斯克曾经被特拉华州法院否决了薪酬方案
被OpenAI踢出了局
这一次
马斯克用美国上市公司历史上
对股东权利限制最严苛的章程设计
把所有对自己不利的情况全部堵死了
招股书中明确写道
公司承认对马斯克的“高度依赖”
他的领导力、愿景与技术专长是公司未来的核心支柱
同时 公司对马斯克的“持续服务”高度依赖
一旦马斯克的参与度下降
将对公司业务、财务状况及未来前景产生“重大不利影响”
对于投资者而言
押注SpaceX
在很大程度上意味着押注马斯克本人
如果你是投资者
面对可能高达1.75万亿美元的市值
你会押注马斯克吗
就在提交招股书的第二天
在经历多次推迟后
新一代V3版星舰完成了首次试飞
这是星舰的第12次试飞
也是自去年11月的爆炸事故后
时隔半年后的首次试飞
V3星舰虽然还叫星舰
但从头到脚都是新的
整箭高度124米
搭载33台全新升级的猛禽3发动机
格栅尾翼增大50%
近地轨道运力从提升到100吨以上
此次试飞中
星舰从新建造的2号发射台起飞
部署了20颗下一代星链模拟器和2颗测试卫星
最终在印度洋受控溅落
此次试飞并不完美
需要解决的问题很多
二级火箭的猛禽3发动机有1台因故障停机
原计划的发动机在轨重启也因此被取消
一级火箭在完成分离后出现燃烧异常
因为是新型号的首次试飞
此次回收没有采用极具视觉冲击力的“筷子夹火箭”
为什么资本市场如此关注此次星舰的试飞
星舰是SpaceX未来图景中最重要的一环
也是1.75万亿市值最重要的支撑
作为目前SpaceX最重要的现金流
星链将换装下一代更重的V3卫星
在轨的9000多颗卫星每年需要补发10%到15%
目前的猎鹰9早已不堪重负
如果星舰不能尽快入轨
SpaceX最赚钱的业务会很快遇到瓶颈
合同金额数十亿美元的重返月球计划也等不起
Artemis IV载人着陆任务定档2028年
而星舰登月架构里最关键的
低温推进剂在轨加注还没有实验
去年10月
NASA罕见的公开质疑SpaceX的登月着陆系统进度
这可能也是为什么
NASA局长Jared Isaacman此次亲自飞到试飞现场观摩
马斯克为资本市场讲的最大故事
太空数据中心
同样需要星舰尽快成熟
计划部署在太空中的AI计算基础设施
需要发射100万颗以上卫星
除了星舰
地球上没有任何火箭能承担这样规模的发射任务
不知道是不是有意的安排
星舰的下一次试飞
按照目前第三方给出的预测是在6月之内
具体哪天还没定
如果安排在IPO当天
我们也许会在同一天见证火箭上天
股价也上天的历史
让我们静待IPO的那一天
关注硅谷101
不要错过最前沿的科技和商业内容